well we woke up to some delightful news
this morning lying disgraced Republican
Congressman George Santos also known to
many as George Anthony De volder Santos
George devolder Anthony devolder Anthony
Santos and all I think that covers most
of the permutations
he has been arrested and is in federal
custody as we speak charged with 13
different criminal counts isn't this
fantastic news and we'll talk about the
Trump 5 million dollar verdict in a
moment
um
what will happen to George Santos now
that he has been arrested maybe this
will get him uh out of Congress which
would be delightful CNN reports George
Santos in federal custody as fed feds
unseal a 13-count indictment we have a
mug shot it's an incredible thing the
justice department Wednesday unsealed
federal charges against Congressman
George Santos and the New York
Republican is in custody is in custody
Santos whose astonishing pattern of lies
and Fabrication stunned even hardened
politicos has been charged on a 13-count
indictment including seven counts of
wire fraud three counts of money
laundering one count of theft of public
funds and two counts of making material
materially false statements to the House
of Representatives this is just a
delight he was taken into custody in
Melville on Long Island where the FBI is
housed from there he was taken to a
courthouse in Central Islip he's
expected to appear later today in
federal court may already happen by the
time you listen to Today's show or watch
the congressman's attorney declined to
comment to CNN spokespeople for the
Brooklyn U.S attorney's Office justice
department and FBI also declined to
comment one of my favorite things is
that he seemed not to even like know
what was going on when it was first
mentioned to him he's like this is news
to me Santos was enroute back to New
York Tuesday night skipping house votes
for the evening according to a source a
spokeswoman for Santos NASA woomer
wouldn't respond to questions shouted
from reporters yesterday abruptly
Departed the congressman's office with a
backpack prior to her departure from the
office CNN witnessed three staffers
abruptly depart with their bags they
wouldn't talk can you imagine you're
working for like the biggest liar in
Congress and now he's arrested it's it's
just a delight a house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy said he's going to look at the
charges before determining whether
Santos should be removed from Congress
quote I'll look at the charges he said
to CNN
Santos was spotted in the capital
earlier yesterday on his way in and out
of McCarthy's office the speaker said he
didn't know why Santos was even there
and that the congressman had not told
him personally about the charges as you
know during his brief time in office
Santos was accused of breaking campaign
Finance laws violating Federal conflict
of interest laws stealing cash meant for
an Iraq war Veteran's dying dog
masterminding a credit card fraud scheme
and lying about where he went to school
and where he worked and I would add to
that lying about his athletic
achievements and lying about so many
different things this is this is really
great and it's not great as some on the
right will say because I just want my
political enemies to have weaponized uh
justice proceedings against them when
there is no evidence they've done
anything wrong it's it's actually quite
the opposite there is so much material
about the wrongdoing of George Santos
including all sorts of different
criminality what's good is that he's
being held accountable he's not being
excused from wrongdoing because he is
one of 435 members of Congress members
of the House of Representatives better
said one of 535 members of of both
houses of Congress that's good when
people are held accountable that's a
good thing the Associated Press
reporting about this as well there's one
particular moment that I love
um this is so good reached on Tuesday
Santos said this is news to me the AP
called him to say hey what do you think
about all the charges and your
forthcoming arrest he was like news to
me I don't know anything about it he
said in a brief phone interview you're
the first to call me about it
that is just just absolutely the best so
we're going to follow this very closely
there are two stories here there is the
story of the charges and the wrongdoing
itself on the one hand and then there is
the story of what do Republicans do many
Republicans have wanted this guy out for
a while but it wasn't really clear they
had the whole party behind them and so
they kind of said listen we have a
process I don't know if we really have
the votes or whatever and they kind of
shut up about it and it to a degree it
went away
um you then had other Republicans who
very much want to get this guy out it
wasn't clear they had a path to do it
before these charges maybe now they do
it's important to remember charges are
merely allegations in the United States
you're innocent until proven guilty in a
court of law however there are many jobs
where if you are charged with certain
crimes you are at minimum suspended from
your job
and then if you are in the future
acquitted then there are different
processes again it's different depending
on the military would be one thing
financial services companies have other
policies so on and so forth there is
latitude from employers of different
kinds as to how charges are handled
given that charges themselves are not
actually guilty verdicts and that's the
system we have and that's a good thing
what do Republicans do now I don't know
but we'll be watching it and delightful
news to wake up to when there's a
non-fiction book I just don't have the
time to read having a summary of the
book is really valuable several
different platforms out there will
summarize books I've tried them all
short form is by far the most impressive
one and it goes Way Beyond what other
platforms do our sponsor short form not
only will Summarize the book covering
all of the key ideas short form also
provides analysis and commentary that
contextual utilizes the book comparing
it to what other books say about the
same topic and you can read or listen to
the entire thing in one sitting for
instance the book dark money by Jane
Mayer about how wealthy Republicans are
covertly influencing American politics
short form clearly and concisely sums up
the book's most important takeaways but
it also gives you a ton of other crucial
background about lobbying libertarianism
and that helps you really understand how
does the book fit into the broader topic
of conservative money in politics that's
why I love short form short form has
every genre politics business Tech
biographies and my audience can try
short form totally free and get 25 off a
subscription at Short form.com Pacman
the link is down below